ha hello and welcome to this video my
audio becomes completely screwed up he
and actually started this game and I
misclicked I didn't want to start that
game but now it started and I might as
well recorded that rocky 21 from the US
okay so I got a king's indian here i'll
go with age three and see what he comes
up with okay some night pg7 setup never
show up i want to go to g5 are you three
if you go age 6 i'm happy that i went 0
King age something that's a weird move
it wasn't strictly necessary hmm yeah
that's about the ideal white set up
that'sthat's at Goose I good as it gets
I get in Bishop e2 g4 h 4 and so on and
it's very nice that he has played age
six and King age seven this makes a
coming g4 h4 h5 especially powerful and
it's difficult for black to prevent in
the first place i might even be able to
play Bishop d3 and Bishop see to that
would be even nicer then Bishop e2
well let's see stuff for him to prevent
that we should be three he might try
bishop f6 in this position nope it
doesn't try anything a five okay so I
think I'll take this opportunity to put
the bishop 1 C 2 mmm now can take you on
c5 is an idea but not not right away
yeah interesting this is something that
I thought of it wasn't sure what you do
even aged 4 is quite interesting each
form Bishop takes the H file is opened
but I mean that's not something that
black is particularly happy with but
let's figure it out if I can play h4
unhindered that probably is excellent I
can even do H for Bishop takes Knight f3
year Bishop g4 gauge form okay it's not
super clear this position it's probably
good for Wyatt but it's not super clear
okay i'll just go night here 3 and
prevent Bishop g5
I have enough interesting I mean oil
interests rings wrong useful moves to
play Queenie to castles long while
blackish is sitting down the bishop on
f6 you can never go f5 obviously ok or
Queen d2 22 is actually just attacking
this pawn that's pretty strong yeah but
you're not going to take on g4 that that
I know opening up the edge farm so let's
see Luke Duke to g1 simply on yeah but
the simple move but it's not a bad one
let's see if what is he doing rook h8
maybe move like that my ideas bishop age
6 cm threatening to take and take on h5
unsure if that is best though the
position looks so awful that maybe have
something better even a rogue age 8
might okay I'm never playing a move that
I expect let's do this as as planned I
need to open up the position and this is
a way to do it just take g7 take h5
okay Jade might still be hmm I mother
just taking this what happens if i take
it I can't take it okay so now to f5 yes
I get h4 in Seoul this is fine I'm sure
that I opened up the position
yeah i will enter into blacks position
the bishop wants it too is the only not
too great piece there should be one
though maybe first of all let's do this
make sure that this is really open up
king of seven probably nope I give up I
never I never gather move that his
playing rook age one I can take f6a here
I can take one g5 Jeff okay so probably
just this check here or queen age 6 what
is better yeah maybe the check I have to
watch out for Bishop g5 this is
something I shouldn't forget about I
don't don't see a big issue though
you
you
tween age 7 didn't help at all check
yeah okay check rejected to strain this
I've got to shine extra points here and
tons of material
I'd like to get this paw down the free
time working 95 or can also knock this
first I mean okay I'm winning this on
time but so also why I didn't play pay
that close attention in recent calls I'm
winning this anyway didn't play it well
absolutely not check okay so check
black resigns you know we resigned okay
yeah there was a pretty serious opening
disaster I mean black black hair not I
mean this is to mosey I think he cannot
afford age six is quite impress ice and
King edge seven is probably yeah it's
very tough to play after that the
computer wants to go e five even for
something more brutal but just what i
did is good because this is just already
excellent for white yeah you have a big
problem here age six is seriously
weakening the King side in a g4 f5
scenario this is the only way for how
black can ever get counter play in this
position and the problem here is that if
you go g for 5 h 6 weakens I mean the
pawn itself is we gon age six square g
six this week and now he even has put
the king on age 7 and this is having
serious issues if the bishop comes to d3
and he has a hard time to prevent that
because if he goes Knight c5 no I'll
just play before and they said yeah no
impact this is what he did and now I
went g4 again if he goes Knight c5 he
has to reckon with with before so he
prevented that and now I get the bishop
even on d3 and if it's on see to that
makes it almost impossible to play a
fight as we see that I'm completely
focused on that square so here if he
would go like f5 here's something like
this there's this it's pretty strong
just this simple continuation is strong
if he tries to take I can't do things
like that and this is why this is a bad
situation for black yeah he tried this
just staying and I played here because
Bishop g5 was annoying I didn't want to
see that you could think of move
like that but this is not completely
clear I saw that line that i mentioned
during during the game but I suspected
that this is better for white because
I've got yeah I could to Bishop c4 rook
and two pawns and the two pawns are not
super strong they cannot move yeah he
cannot go f5 g5 whatever but it's not
totally clear this position so I just
kept the position as is because black is
sitting there without any play 97 yeah
just and doesn't do anything yeah okay
and the computer was as usual University
this takes that porn that's actually
strong because its position is so
passive that I can just take it and play
it for next okay but I just keep
everything as it is said it is some just
not another client in position check
jess was check okay check ya here i have
to admit dash and i just said okay he
will lose on time anyway and i didn't
didn't look so closely if this is the
best that is a winning endgame but
probably I should have been able to get
something better and I'd be fine I
should've played that's a lot a lot more
precise what's more active okay yeah at
the end this was due to the opening the
moon firm
age six and should be avoided already at
King edge seven in particular the
combination of two moose is hard too
hard to play for black okay thanks for
watching